انضم الينا من رم الله مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري وليد هل من صدن للخبر الذي
اوردته القسام عن فقدان الاتصال بمجموعه
كانت مهمتها حراسه
ال الاسرى الاسرائيليين الخمسه وترجيح
مقتلهم بينهم
الثلاثه الذين سبق ان وجهوا رساله
لنتنياهو هل لهذا الخبر اي صدى في
اسرائيل رسميا ليس هناك اي تعقيب ل هذا
الخبر لكن وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه رات
بان هذا جزءا من الحرب النفسيه هدفه
محاوله القاء المسؤوليه عن مصير وعن حياه
الماسورين والمحتجزين الاسرائيليين في
قطاع غزه على الجانب الاسرائيلي وعلى جيشه
اي محاوله لتعزيز التوجه داخل الشارع
الاسرائيلي الذي يحذر من ان استمرار القصف
بالطائرات واستمرار العمليه البريه يعرض
حياه المحتجزين الاسرائيليين في قطاع غزه
للخطر هكذا قراته وسائل الاعلام
والمراقبين في اسرائيل لكن رسميا لم يتم
التعامل معه حتى هذه الساعه وبالنسبه
لاسرائيل تتحدث عن ان هناك
129 اسيرا
ومحتجزة
سواء بالوصول اليهم او من خلال عمليه
ابرام صفقات تبادل بهذا الشان المعلومات
في اسرائيل ان رغم استمرار التواصل بهذا
الخصوص والمفاوضات الا انها وصلت الى طريق
المسدود ولكن يعني هكذا تعاملت وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه مع الخبر او هكذا
فسرته لكن على المستوى الشعبي على مستوى
اللجان الخاصه بمتابعه قضيه هؤلاء المح
محتجزين الاسرائيليين في
غزه كيف يمكن ان يكون التاثير لهكذا خبر
ونحن نتابع اسبوعيا مظاهرات
لاهالي المحتجزين في تل
ابيب يوميا هناك مظاهرات وهذا المساء ايضا
هناك مظاهره في تل ابيب هؤلاء لديهم قلق
شديد وكانوا في الاسابيع الاخيره قد
ضاعفوا من مجهودهم في محاوله للضغط على
الحكومه وحملوها المسؤوليه وطالبوا بان
يكون هناك وقف تام لاطلاق النار حتى لو
كان مقابل افراج ابرام صفقه تبادل الكل في
مقابل الكل رفعوا شعارات بهذه الخصوص
واخرى تطالب نتنياهو بالتنحي هؤلاء
يتاثرون كثيرا في مثل هذه الاخبار لان لدي
تساور القلق والمخاوف من بدايه هذه الحرب
البريه من انها قد تؤدي فعلا الى مقتل ايه
اقربائهم المحتجزين في قطاع غزه ومما عزز
من هذا الشعور لديهم هو ما جرى قبل نحو
اسبوعين عندما قتل الجنود الاسرائيليين
ثلاثه من الاسرى الذين كانوا قد افلتوا من
داخل الحجز وحاولوا الوصول الى الجيش الا
انه اطلق النيران عليهم فزادت المخاوف لدى
هؤلاء الذين يواصلون مظاهراتهم في منطقه
تل ابيب